like much of Scotland's political
Landscape East Lothian was labor for
decades in Preston pans they used to
mine coal to heat homes
now energy costs are so high this
project has been launched to offer older
people a warm room and a hot drink and
everyone has a view on Independence it
sounds good in theory I would love to be
independent
but this country's got to pay its way
and there isn't enough people
and do you want Scotland to be
independent
yeah I know poverty levels are a concern
here yet most vote based on their view
of Scotland's constitutional future
[Applause]
the 2014 Independence referendum
transformed Scottish politics and while
the SMP may have been the losers the
dream shall never die within months they
were winning at the 2015 general
election as the pro UK vote split three
ways most pro-independent Scots backed
the SMP and it will not be
the Nationalist 156 of Scotland's 59
seats I will also table my resignation
as leader of the Scottish labor party
labor went from 41 to 1. so that
structural Advantage has kept the SMP on
winning form but will it last if that
relationship between whether you support
Independence or the union and how you
vote in the election if that starts to
break down
um then that will be primarily of course
to Labor's advantage
Nicola sturgeon's departure was always
going to be a game changer for Scottish
labor party sources argue between 10 and
20 Westminster seats like this one are
now in play they could help kierstama
get into Downing Street but rebuilding a
battered party takes time as one labor
strategist explained their ground
operation off the border is now
practically non-existent
you're okay to stand up let's come
standing Mr Yousaf has spent the last
two years running Scotland's struggling
Health Service
everyone here has experience of the NHS
yet so far the new SMP leader doesn't
seem to have made much of an impression
what do you think of Hamza Yousaf
um
been interested in smp's policies
raising his profile will be easy
securing a path to leaving the UK may
not after decades in politics Nicholas
surgeon now has her independence
achieving that for Scotland will be a
lot more difficult Joe Pike Sky News
East Lothian